India's prime minister Narendra Modi at
the site of the worst train crash this
Century where three collided and
hundreds of lives were lost
this is a very big painful and
disturbing incident those family members
who have been injured the government
will spare no effort for their
well-being those who have lost will not
come back the government is with the
families in the hour of grief
their survival hanging in the balance
the wreckage is an apocalyptic mass of
Twisted steel and harrowing stories
where Rescuers labored frantically
we were stuck inside and somehow managed
to get out we broke the grills and when
we came out we saw many dead bodies
piled up
when the accident happened we all fell
and there was a short circuit and two of
my children got shocked and we all
screamed and begged for Allah's help
my children are okay but they have got
hurt in their chest and legs but okay
I am deeply distressed
by this
extremely tragic train accident
I have to thank the local people
the local teams and others
who have worked overnight
to save people from the wreckage
train safety standards in India are once
again under the microscope the
government has made improvements but
human error and outdated signaling are
still major issues and with 12 million
people traveling on 14
000 trains every day it is a system
under pressure
Prime Minister Modi was due to launch a
series of new high-speed trains today to
highlight his government's expanded
infrastructure investment as he seeks a
third term in office instead he was
visiting a devastating scene with an
exceptionally High death toll even for a
country with a long history of deadly
crashes
in the wake of the tragedy locals rushed
to give blood
others spent the night pulling bodies
from crumpled carriages
families are being transported to their
loved ones by train a long and haunting
journey and with every hour comes more
grief
more questions
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Kolkata India
but despite government efforts to
improve rail safety several hundred
accidents occur every year on India's
Railways the largest train Network under
one Management in the world more than 12
million people rise over 14
000 trains across India every day and
hundreds of people who have been killed
in accidents the worst disaster was in
1981 when at least 800 people were
killed when seven rare coaches of an
overcrowded passenger train were blown
off the track and fell into a river
during a cyclone in August 1995 at least
350 people died when two trains collided
125 miles from Delhi 212 people died
when an Express train collided with
three derailed coaches of another
service in 1998.
when two trains collided near Kolkata
just a year later at least 285 people
were killed in 2005 77 people died when
a Train derailed in the southern state
of Andhra Pradesh in 2016 around 146
people died and more than 200 were
injured when an Express Train derailed
in the northern state of Usher Pradesh
just a year later at least 41 people
were killed that's in 2017 after several
coaches of a passenger train went off
the rails in southern Andhra Pradesh
State well earlier we spoke to Rakesh
Chopra a former board member of India's
Railways he said the trains in India are
far different to those in other parts of
the world
see as a matter of fact the composition
of the trains in India is very much
unlike in countries abroad we have 26
coaches 24 coaches 26 coaches and we
still do have the parcel Vans and the
guard bands at the two ends so that was
the Saving Grace after the engine that
was there so the number of people that
were traveling in each of these trains
in the first two coaches which collided
more than 300 to 350 people were there
or maybe even 400 people and those are
the two coaches really capsized and that
is why the numbers are so high